there are two stories that came together
last night in this sort of explosion of
incompetence and also impotence when it
comes to some policy so on the one hand
you have Donald Trump's constant
turnover in his cabinet his cabinet
members high-level staffers just really
really high rate of turnover sometimes
Trump forcing people out sometimes Trump
people deciding they can't work with
Trump and that's been one issue on the
other hand you have the immigration
Fiasco which involves the fake crisis at
the border it includes Trump's total
inability to make good on even a
fraction of the immigration promises
that he made I guess most comically the
border wall across the entire us-mexico
border which Mexico was going to pay for
which no one with any kind of common
sense of rationality believed even from
the get-go those have been sort of two
parallel stories but they came together
last night out with Donald Trump's
homeland security secretary
Kirsten Nielsen resigning as Donald
Trump continues to say totally
unintelligible things about the wall and
immigration which I'm going to get to a
little bit later as Donald Trump
continued to call Kirsten Nielsen early
in the morning at home asking her to do
things that her best assessment was were
illegal Donald Trump now pushing her out
and the the the explanation we've gotten
so far is that her resignation was not
voluntary but that she didn't grovel or
ask to keep her job either she put out a
statement late afternoon early evening
yesterday saying in part quote I have
determined that it is the right time for
me to step aside I hope that the next
secretary will have the support of
Congress and the courts in fixing the
laws which have impeded our ability to
fully secure America's borders and which
have contributed to discord in our
nation's discourse the way it seems this
thing went down according to the New
York Times yesterday is that she had a
meeting with Donald Trump at the White
House and as far as she knew the meeting
really was to figure out a plan but
clearly it didn't go well
CNN saying
didn't resign willingly but she also
wasn't groveling to keep her job as I
mentioned so here's the chaos that this
is all sandwiched between which you
really need to understand in order to
get the context in which all of this
stuff is happening Donald Trump
nominated Ron video low to run ice
immigration and customs enforcement and
then very quickly withdrew the
nomination because he decided he wanted
someone tougher than Ron video low total
chaos Trump went on a completely
unintelligible rant about the number of
doors that Obama and Bush didn't put in
some areas of border wall which Trump
maybe is going to put in but maybe not I
know that doesn't make any sense but I'm
gonna play the video for you a little
bit later Trump as I mentioned has been
calling Kirsten Nielsen early in the
mornings at home to tell her to do
aggressive things including certain
things that are illegal like for example
blocking or not allowing requests for
asylum at the border which just it's
just against the law and Kirsten Nielsen
as extreme and outrageous and
reactionary as she is recognized that
those requests would violate the law if
she actually did it and it's important
to note that normally when the
Department of Homeland Security
Secretary resigns the deputy DHS
secretary would take over except there's
no DHS
deputy secretary so instead the
commissioner of Customs and Border
Protection is going to take over for now
complete and total disarray and adding
to this kind of comedy of errors and
surreal nature of this farce there are
reports that the person Trump is
thinking about of nominating to replace
Christine Nielsen is former Virginia
Attorney General Ken Cuccinelli who is
most well known for wanting to make oral
sex illegal in the state of Virginia
that's the guy that rumor has it Donald
Trump is considering nominating to
replace the Kerstin nielsen so this is
one of those which is worse the cure the
disease sort of situations because on
the one hand Pat Kirsten Nielsen is a
completely disgusting conservative
reactionary on immigration it's good
that she's out but Donald Trump wants to
put someone in who's even more
disgustingly reactionary and he may
actually get it and this is a pattern
we've seen before Pat we saw it with
Mike Pompeo replacing Rex Tillerson we
saw it with Jeff Sessions being replaced
by William bar I mean listen Jeff
Sessions is a horrible racist ideologue
but at least he realized he had to
recuse himself on Russia Trump replaced
them with a guy who's part of the
cover-up of the molar reports so I don't
know what's worse again the cure of the
disease yeah and remember Kirsten
Nielson was perfectly fine with going
along with the policy that ice would
separate children from their families
she didn't protest then she didn't
announce the resignation maybe Trump
demanded something of her that was even
worse I mean that's what this kind of
suggests and I'd have to imagine that
her replacement is going to be even
worse than she was going along with
policy like that who knows yeah and like
I said we know what he requested he was
requesting that she as policy stop
accepting asylum requests at the border
which she felt and lawyers believe is
illegal and and against the law so
certainly was
as we mentioned asking for things that
are far worse that we know of and
potentially even more that we don't so
she was horrible more than likely will
be replaced with someone who comes in
and is just willing to do Trump's
bidding we've seen that with Mike Pompeo
we've seen it with others people leave
who are horrible but then they're
replaced with others who are completely
subjugated by Trump and willing to do
his dirty work even if it crosses the
ethical moral or sometimes even legal
lines so who were we going to see
ultimately replace Christine Nielsen we
don't know but complete and total
disarray around the continuing Fiasco
that is the Trump immigration not even
policy it's like failed policy or policy
that doesn't actually come to be despite
Trump's best wishes or most sincere
wishes if you love learning new things
you probably want to check this out the
David Pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months to free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than
twenty-five thousand video classes on
just about anything you can think of get
better at playing an instrument learn to
use Photoshop how to edit videos they
have classes on drawing painting
business cooking nutrition personal
productivity and I'm not even really
scratching the surface I recently took a
great class on introductory watercolour
painting I'm still not good but I am
learning and you can access the entire
library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video